the man from  i always get wrong he's from gdansk  right i think so yeah  we've established that at some point and  then yeah  man is man is seriously good at chess  girls magnus is a little stared out did  you see that chess 24 and a half  duda gives magnus a little look  yeah but it does feel it does feel like  a  like a correct correct approach in in  terms of  ev as as you've alluded to  yeah and often of course you have the  risk of looking stupid yeah if you  end yet they may drop they just  immediately draw here yeah  because the a7 and b3 pawns just come  off the board very very quickly here  um so yeah this one is over i have a  feeling the other one is  not particularly long for this world  either  in in the men's section they've been  shuffling without really  progressing either way for a while now  and uh  i think they must be nearing move 30 so  yeah game could end at any moment now